after years of going through a lot of
different things I realized virus
bipolar Selena Gomez is opening up about
her mental health like never before on
Friday during an appearance on Miley
Cyrus's Instagram live show bright
minded Selena revealed that she's
bipolar something she says she learned
after a recent visit to McLean Hospital
in Boston after years of going through a
lot of different things I realized I was
bipolar
educating herself on the mental health
disorder has helped her cope with the
diagnosis I wanted to know everything
about it and it took the fear away the
singer also shared that she's received
treatment for other issues as well
I had gone to treatment a few times for
anxiety and for depression and for other
stuff that I had been struggling with
she noted that she's using some of the
things she learned in therapy to help
her cope during this challenging time of
social distancing due to the corona
virus pandemic I definitely just tried
to use the tools I've used when I've
been in therapy which is amazing
I've been writing a lot I think that
that's been helped helping me process
what's been going on Selena and Miley
had a little bit of a technical
difficulty and Selena's camera froze but
you can still hear what Selena had to
say about how we should all be kind to
each other and to ourselves as we battle
through this together
this is where we test each other like
how are we going to treat each other it
can be a time to be gentle with
ourselves like you said taking breaks
from all the noise even taking breaks
from social media for a second and just
you know being outside or being with my
babies outside and like just just
breathing in and Selena says she's
leaning on some of her close friends and
I think talking through what it is
you're feeling is extremely helpful but
sometimes I have to feel it really
sometimes I got a cried out and I've got
to release it and just take a deep
breath and then remind myself you know
go back to my tools which is okay where
is this coming from
and I'm a big empath so I feel so much
of what the world is feeling so maybe I
need to take a step up from that or or
or whatever it is but also just being
being there for other people actually
helps me to this totally echoes what
Selena told ET back in 2017 I think that
for me I'm really big on vulnerability I
think people are really scared to be
honest with themselves and strength is
looked upon as oh I'm strong I don't
need anything I can't I can handle
everything and that's just not the truth
and I think that's the message I want I
want people to know that every every
single life is valuable but there are
people who are willing to be there for
them
[Music]